[موسيقى]
المشهد الاعلامي الامريكي يمر على ما يبدو
في مرحله تغييرات جديده وتحدثنا عن ديزني
والمحتوى الترفيهي وسنتحدث الان عن سي ان
ان والمحتوى الاخباري الرئيس الجديد
للشبكه الاخباريه الاشهر كريس لخت يريد ان
يعيد مؤسسه الى الوسط لان الواقع واضح وهو
ان السي ان ان
انجرفت كثيرا في موجه العداله الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب الشبكه الاخباريه
الاولى في الولايات المتحده وجدت بحسب
تحليلات نشرتها الصحف الامريكيه ان الجنوح
الى اليسار افقدها موقعها الاكثر اهميه
وربما اكثر ربحيه في الوسط الرئيس الجديد
يرى بانه يتعين على الشبكه ان تبقى وافيه
لفكرتها الرئيسيه وهي ان الخبر هو النجم
وليس الراي ولابد من الخروج من شركه ترامب
العاصفه ولو ان ترامب ربما يعود
لكن هذا الراي ليس الراي الوحيد على
الطاوله كثيرون يعتقدون بان مكان الوسط في
مجتمع منقسم ليس هناك جمهور في المنتصف
بحسب ذلك الراي الاخر